three two we're watching the h3h3
vodka podcast let's crank it up a little
bit
what you going to do
jay-z everybody welcome everybody to
h3 after dark our live
show where anything could happen
we've got a lot of show here today
there's a lot of fun developments
there's some shots fired
i may even be blowing the horn of
war foot soldiers assemble
all right you know what i understand i'm
a few minutes late but you all cannot be
threatening to take my wikifeed score
like
like that's just you don't know that
people get fired for example if they're
late to their job
it's my show who's going to fire me
then the audience
but it's just not fair you guys i'm out
here trying to put together the best
show possible and you all
threaten to take my wiki feet like come
on that's not right
you know hey i think
they have a right to i think that's you
live by the foot you die by the foot my
friend
it's the way of the world you know
you've made it warrior
you know um well anyway today's episode
is sponsored by
viori and adam and eve do you think
trisha is gonna be pissed at adam and
eve sponsoring
us it had nothing to do with her right
they came they came through us through
our other agents they came on to us
they came to me don't have anyone tell
trisha that adam and eve is sponsoring
us i think she watches this show
yeah she says she's well don't be stupid
well anyway there's
i i'm not kidding there's so many good
things to get to
uh but first let's start with something
heartwarming
really white claw gabe who i gave a
shout out recently who's my yeah
one of my favorite uh oh my thing kind
of got a little goofy
um the fry i love fried [ __ ] chicken
guy
he saw the shout out and he he
reciprocated you wanted to say thanks so
i thought hey let's start with some
some hey ethan yeah thanks for the
support
i appreciate you i appreciate your
support yeah
let's have a white class someday yeah
i'd like to meet you someday yeah let's
have a [ __ ] good time
yeah baby yeah
hey ethan yeah thanks for the support i
appreciate you i appreciate you
wasn't that nice of them that's really
nice i like what
i gave i just started chickens [ __ ]
wednesday
it's [ __ ] wednesday i deserve fried
[ __ ] chicken
i love i just you know you do deserve
fried chicken
yeah okay you goddamn dew everybody
deserves who deserves fried chicken
meat
um you want to talk about your new teddy
fresh release
um just had tea with your mom
new grass oh yeah we have some fun stuff
to look at here
so we have like a cool retro hoodie this
just came out
uh yesterday it's a little bit of a mini
drop
next month you know next month we'll
have a bigger collection but this was
just kind of because of code everything
keeps getting separated
yeah but this was fun retro graphic
shirt graphic yeah neon green and new
now talk about this one um
yeah well guess who came up with that
sentence
go ahead ethan thank you um
[Music]
yeah it's just some cool graphics i
don't know
do you like it i was debating do you
like it i was debating if it was funny
or not i
i do and i we've done a vibe check with
the whole
team if we should keep it or not and
they all voted to keep it so
that's good i was thinking about
removing it but it's not like a sexual
thing
in my opinion it's just funny yeah it's
more like no i i just had
like this is badass biker who just had
tea with your mom because he's
a softy yeah not because he [ __ ] her
because he's a teddy bear
yeah it's funny it's funny yeah it's
cool i
i like it that but the illustration is
sick yeah that's our room
we have um eli our graphic designer
who's just
a super talent oh actually sorry well he
did the flames
but yeah sorry so that reminds me that's
it you got socks you get the other
design yada yada
teddyfish.com okay is there any uh teddy
fresh stuck in the suez canal right now
what's happening with that
[Laughter]
you guys don't know about the story
about the suez canal no what is that
there's a
so there's a giant ship a cargo ship got
stuck
side like they austin powered it they
like got stuck
yeah it's been like that like all week i
think it happened on like tuesday how
does that happen
where's the media show him oh
there's pictures i want to see that
dan's a good man
i thought you were saying where's the
media like nobody's nobody's covering
this it's oh
no no it's causing like a huge
disruption to uh thank you love
sent me so explain to me what the [ __ ]
am i looking at here
how does that happen block the whole
thing like nobody can get through
my god and they're totally stuck
they're totally stuck they're trying to
like excavate it out it's actually it's
like grounded on the side so it's like
yeah so who's drunk grandpa
as far as i've seen that there no like
real info has come out if it was like
if they did it on purpose if it was an
accident because that that's a canal
you're supposed to go straight
yeah that would be pretty funny it's
something to do on purpose
like i mean not funny a day of wrecking
will come papa was possibly captaining
this ship
what's the [ __ ] disrupting global trade
papo
shout out to the evergreen
love that all right listen
guys i'm gonna talk about david dobrik
and jeff whitake more but i'm
telling you there's a good reason we
have to follow the story
through all the way at this point we're
in too
deep but it's all good stuff you
promised
you promised i tried i listened to a
promise i tr
what was the promise well last night but
it was that was the last thing we were
going to talk about
i don't think it was a promise i think
it was a more of and now may i please
never talk about david
it was more of a plea than a problem but
i do feel like i owe
after the amount that i ripped into jeff
yeah i feel like he's done a good deed
and i owe it to him
that's what we love to recognize and one
thing i want
so jeff jeff weddick who we
criticized his video he called and you
guys all remember
he uploaded he deleted and uploaded a
new video now first thing i want to
debate
no oh all right so i deleted my list why
did i open that like that
like what just opened the video youtube
why you all got
what the [ __ ] is this all right youtube
why you always got to change your [ __ ]
up on me
it's it's just opening yeah like it's a
tiny box
we'll do it live
all right my last video titled my truth
and never that so i deleted my last
video don't be like that
well do we like you the way you are
[Laughter]
they're like okay when is after truck
dark um
12 at friday let's push a new update
okay here's the first issue first i'm
going to like it because
i appreciate it oh wow we can debate if
we want to remove it later but i think
it's
like look at the
and title just a period i like that
is that new that's new it's kind of
avant-garde when it comes to uh
apology because his last one was just a
date
and i thought oh this is avant-garde but
then somebody said who would
have you guys who said you'd seen that
before so i had the the the dated
the yeah the date apologies has anyone
ever seen a
period before i i don't know if i have
yeah that might be novel
i like
wasn't david's the date and jeff's was
yeah
jeff was just my truth which is that is
[ __ ] lazy
yeah david's was the day my truth my
truth is like
david also had the famous let's talk
let's talk let's talk with comments off
the market
[Laughter]
so my truth was a disaster yeah
but the dot is fascinating if i have to
ever make an epic apology
video like this i wonder i would
consider it i would consider it because
it's like how do you title an apology
and also they've all been done before
and it's they all
are they feel so charged it's like not
another i'm sorry
not another i messed up yeah you're not
trisha had a really good idea i don't
know if you saw but she says whenever
she has a video like this
she just she doesn't edit the video file
and makes that that's
right yeah and mov
seven one three that's very attrition
and i like that that's pretty good too i
thought
okay boomer
all right let's watch you know my heart
does go
go out to jeff a little bit i know the
guy's going through hard times but here
let's give him a fair shake here and see
what he has to say
all right so i deleted my last video
titled my truth because turns out i had
some things wrong from my memory
and there was a lot of things i said
wrong and did wrong in that video
because i acted out of emotion
and impulse and frustration that my name
was even mentioned in it
and i said i didn't want to discredit
the victim but by discrediting the
reporter and my
small minuscule part in the story i did
just that i
think he also ditched the second camera
so far oh
no second cam it's better
well i don't even know if necessarily
there's a cut in this one which will
happen there was already a tiny cut but
it was very tiny
still a single camera though that's but
it sounds like he's read the article
first of all which is a good idea
because he said it was just a small
minuscule as part of the of the article
which it was
yeah so props on jeff first of all for
reading it we love that
and for removing the first video love
that
credited the entire story that this girl
worked up the courage to tell
and i feel horrible about it and i just
want to apologize i truly believe
hannah's story i respect her for coming
forward
and telling it it takes a lot
and to have somebody like me come on and
just focus on myself and my part of the
story and saying that it was
a lie just because i was i was selfish
and
i didn't want to be mentioned in this
act at all
imagine if something like being did
and then nothing happens to that person
but they keep growing and keep getting
more successful
and keep making the same jokes i had to
take some time to think
about all this in david's video he said
that he got the text
three months after the incident happened
i wasn't filled in on this for whatever
reasons i don't know if it was because
he thought i would attack dom
or maybe he didn't want to tell anyone
to protect his squeaky clean brand
that's not cool they should have been
informed
i love this from jay yeah first of all
owning up big time yeah to being like
you know it was selfish of me
to try to get just to be only obsessed
with
how this affected me yeah and also
really
interesting because this is possibly the
first time i've ever seen a
a um a member of his gr
friend group ever lay any responsibility
on david himself he's like david got
this text message
three months after yeah
and he didn't tell him he didn't tell
any of us
they're part of this video they should
have been informed at least
yeah what they were a part of and also
jeff also acknowledges which is really
a good it's like so so david knows this
happened
and yet he continued to portray dom as
this
lovable uh you know
this lovable he's just just a little
creepy
predator yeah yeah just your
your your friendly neighborhood predator
so so so far
jeff's hitting all the right notes for
me at the time
i don't know there's no excuse for it
it's just not something you hide
and i wasn't told and i was in the video
and i was acting
in [ __ ] and i stand by that i was
looking in a room
and i didn't witness anything but
something horrible did happen
and people knew about it and they didn't
tell me and
i didn't find out until the reporter
reached out with this article
because the state of mind i'm in once
again my point is like
your anger is misplaced yeah your anger
should be towards
david right who knew who put you in that
situation and who knew what happened and
still allowed you guys all to just laugh
about the situation and go and attack
the reporter
i can't i can't get over the fact that
david got that text like three
months after and kept it a secret that
should have been a big like hey guys we
need to talk
you know and and kept continuing with
dom
yeah like as if nothing happened
i acted off impulse and anger that my
name was even a part of it
and i apologize for that i don't even
have the courage to tell you guys what
happened to me
so for me to discredit this girl for
coming forward and talking about
a traumatic thing that happened to her
and it had to be
extremely hard to come forward and say
it and i'm supposed to be this tough guy
and i can't even tell you what happened
to me because i'm scared
of the criticism i would get in return i
don't know if i would be able to deal
with it
there's no contracts there's no ndas
there's no lawsuits
i just don't know if i could take it
because i know how i got hurt was stupid
and i'm embarrassed of it and i've
been acting irrational lately i've
undergone various surgeries on my eye
and my head and i had brain trauma
i've been on meds and that's why i
stutter and that's probably some cuts in
this video
but [ __ ] it i'm gonna try my best to be
completely transparent
and vulnerable and honest and
i'll probably [ __ ] up on a couple things
but when they asked me about the article
i didn't know what to say
i didn't want to speak about my
health and my my vision my [ __ ]
eye i'm embarrassed of and
i see like a camera that's out of focus
i
i see complete blur out of my left eye
and it [ __ ] up both my vision
so it's difficult for me to read and i
had the article read to me
and that's still no excuse i could have
had it read to me
30 times and got every detail right but
i let my emotions get the best to me
because of just me being selfish
and that's it i tried to blindly defend
my friends when
truthfully if something like this
happens you need to speak about it
you need to tell people you need to take
action because
you can't cover [ __ ] like this up this
girl spoke up
and told her story three months after it
happened
and then everybody continued to keep
making these jokes
and including myself if i was the victim
and i continued to watch these videos
and and
see that i was still associating with
dom and i was making j i made a joke
with dom
that they separate the sexual i mean
i literally said something based off a
character that i thought
that we all had an understanding of that
this was just a character
when he was a known abuser
and i i had jokes come out after the
situation and after people knew about
that and that doesn't sit right with me
so obviously there's a respect level
here that's off
and i don't stand for that i'm gonna
take a step back i'm gonna
be accountable for myself and that's it
obviously i need to take some time to
heal
and get my [ __ ] together i'll do just
that i'll work on myself
and i'm gonna try to grow from this
experience
if this video gets torn apart and it's
my last video and it gets a million
dislikes and i get [ __ ] ripped apart
again
but it got at least one person to speak
up and
one person to get help or call and
just talk just get your story out there
if you know somebody if you know
somebody that's
that's assaulted someone even if they're
your your
best friend or your own [ __ ] family
member you need to speak about it
the story is getting a lot of attention
all over um
youtube and and articles being published
and
it's become a form of almost
entertainment for people because of
everyone that's involved
and it's not entertainment
at all this is a girl's life and it's a
it's a thing she'll have to live with
for the rest of her life and
if you're making money on it i'd
understand
businesses need to keep their lights on
and and people need to make money
and that's how the world works but just
try to help just do anything you can to
help
i feel like you should i suggest you
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] what anybody
else does i can't be accountable for
anybody but myself
i chose to donate to rain rain is a
charity for essay victims
it's a hotline as well if you want to
call them and talk
you can do it for free this is an
ongoing situation that needs to be
talked about you cannot keep things like
this a secret
and if you know anybody just call and
talk if you've been assaulted
call and talk i appreciate you know
everybody
educating me more on this situation
because
you know that's what life's about that's
what that's all we can really do is
learn and grow
from these situations and try to help
other people
jeff wow let's donate to the
rain organization
well guess what jeff that's i don't
think this is getting torn apart and i
think this was
just exactly perfect
yeah it was perfect it's like he said he
was coming
what do you want to do like 10th let's
give 10 000 to rain
whatever rain is mm-hmm someone look up
what's
rain before i give money to it no i'm
pulling it up right now
i've uh i i think it's a pretty legit
organization though because i've
heard of it before i'm sorry i was muted
yeah it's the nationals
i'm sorry the nation's largest
anti-sexual violence organization
next i love i love that i'm gonna i'm
gonna don't
we are gonna donate ten thousand dollars
to rain
and um it's like he said he was trying
to cover for his friends
i feel bad for him i feel yeah i think
like me and trisha always said we're
like you know we
feel that jeff's a good guy like he's
always done the right
you know i i believe i believe that if
he saw something bad he would
if anyone's at fault it's david for
hiding the fact that he knew this
three months after it happened yeah i
mean i don't need to read the text again
i read it before
but the text message that hannah sent
to dom was extremely
graphic extremely detailed extremely
genuine
and jump dom basically said k
the the video the video is gone and you
know david saw because it was on david's
channel yeah so
yeah once again it's like who are your
real friends
david put you in the situation but i
like
jeff i think he did the right thing and
i feel like with the amount of
the amount of uh criticism we laid at
his feet and the scrutiny that we laid
on him when he was here
the fact that he came out here and did
the right thing i felt like
i i needed to show that mm-hmm yeah
so good job to jeff yeah that was really
i don't know i was kind of tearing up i
feel bad
it's just it's a lot i feel bad
i don't know i don't know what happened
with the injury but it seems like that
poor guy really got
really got mangled up whatever happened
so there's that so so good job jeff man
i'm happy
i'm happy i'm proud
yeah i i feel bad too so i'm not gonna
fight him anymore
whatever i said i feel bad too so so i'm
not gonna fight him anymore
i'm not gonna box him anymore oh i told
ab if you agree because
jeff came on and challenged a b to a
boxing max i said dude just go
well yeah he thought he was challenging
yeah i said av just go for his bad eye
you'll take him out in the first round
yeah everyone always mixes me up for dan
i'm always the guy simping dan's the one
not hating in the background not me
then the hater
so you of all the people involved jeff
is the guy
who did the right thing after doing the
wrong thing
but also i mean not getting a full
information on what was happening
right he didn't know it's kind of like
acting from
being misinformed for a long time yeah
so shout out to jeff and his family
um other news regarding the vlog
squad david dobrik you'll be all be
happy to know
has is funny it's funny at what it took
to
for to make this happen he will no
longer be a part
of the no place for hate anti-bowlering
tour
no way bye bye it took
it it only took a mere
a small account of assault
and covering up and deflecting
and let's see
pranking what he did to seth which was
another essay
bowling big neck
well trisha talking for years already
too yeah
so but but you know sadly david will no
longer being teenagers
not to bully oh who famously said
let's not forget do you have the
soundbite zack of what he of what
jason was like they used to throw
pennies at my feet
and he's like you'd have to be a [ __ ]
or an [ __ ] to be offended by that
no i do not have that one you got you
can you follow that for me
sure thank you yeah he famously said
jason was like yeah i used to get
bullied all the time in high school
people would throw pennies at my feet
and say pick it up joe and he's like oh
you'd have to be an
[ __ ] and a [ __ ] to be offended by
that
anyway thanks for attending my no
bowling tour
love it um
this is huge news you guys
this shocked me
the author of the original story cat ten
barge
she says we have finally received a
response from youtube about david dobrik
and dom i still can't say his last name
zegliagas
segali
uh monetization has been temporarily
suspended from
both of their channels that's
a lot for youtube dude i who's that
who's that happened to other than logan
paul
that i can recall um
g station
rest j station's in a in a
in a graveyard someone trying to ouija
board his career
what the freak
um he's up in heaven with sonic exe now
sonic.exe
yeah youtube stepped in and demonetized
dave
david dobrik that took me advice such a
surprise because i'm so used to youtube
just not saying anything and not ever
responding to anything
yeah they weren't involved really no i
was like oh wait youtube right like
oh they commented nice could you think
they probably would have taken down some
of his videos or something but no just
straight d monetized so
well that's but that is a big um huge
punishment what i what i
what i would guess happen is they go
i'm demonetizing your whole channel
until
people in the chat are saying shane got
the same treatment oh right
yeah oh shane got this treatment after
the whole smith family
do you think it was because he [ __ ] on
his cat
i mean that's part of the story it's
because there's like
so much and how do you start to separate
which videos are okay and which are not
you just shut it all down
yeah i understand it yeah
good thing we don't have a cat i
couldn't even choose on a cat i don't
even own a cat
i'm here live that's not i'm not a cat
i keep trying to want to eat a pair but
i know i shouldn't the parrot
let me take that for you thank you it's
almost like just a reflex
so that's huge oh but another
interesting development because i can't
stop now what do you think of this
well now exactly what now
david dobrik he might be [ __ ] on
youtube
but he's sure that his [ __ ] [ __ ] up on
facebook oh yeah facebook delights the
resort
um he's going the soflo antonio
uh that dude and joey salads too right
yeah
on the meat shop facebook
is the graveyard of youtube
but it's you've it's almost turned into
this place where you can make even more
money on facebook now but listen to this
deaf noodle shout out to deaf noodles
who we love david dobrik's videos are
being
re-uploaded to his facebook page okay
oh wow look at the views oh my god
three minutes ago he's really 5.2
million
no so he's actively doing that right now
he's looking at this look at this i'm
telling you four minutes ago five
million
five hours ago two million
what five days ago five million
i don't i i don't believe it five days
ago twenty doesn't make any sense
five million in five minutes
how is that possible my tesla flew off
the ground
i mean it's facebook bro well amy can
you fact check this like what's going on
what's actually going on on facebook
so i mean i was trying to figure out if
he paid
to get them pushed because i don't know
how they could spread that fast like
yeah five minutes
yeah i did go to his facebook those
numbers are correct um
jesus i feel like facebook just lies
about their views
to try and promote their videos
yeah it is to an extent because like
every time you scroll by that's a view
right dude your hair looks so good thank
you
the color came out crazy like lush
it's nice i like the red onion yeah i
love this girl jessie she just does the
best
i never had fun with my hair like this
like she
every time i would go to a barber shop
or in her son
whatever the right word is i would
always hate it afterwards like it was
never a positive experience
you know what's fun about this too is
that as it fades it looks
cool it just still looks yeah it changes
everything it's like a new look
anyone that never dyed their hair i
actually recommend it i think it's
really fun
yeah you look wonderful trying at least
love a fun mom so
can you send me a link i want to look at
his actual facebook page can you send me
a link
so this is how this is what happens on
these facebook pages because i know
people who do it i've had people reach
out to me because you know maintaining
facebook is like
is a nightmare so what happens is you
work with a
third party who basically retake
takes all of your footage re-uploads
manages spams the [ __ ] out of it and
then they just take a cut of the revenue
which is quite a bit on facebook these
days
so but it can be a lot of work so that's
fine oh no
it's a great deal yeah but i'm just
saying you can make a lot of money
david's still making a [ __ ] load of
money you know
this was uploaded yesterday yeah my
tesla flew off the ground
how many views does it have why is
everything so impossible to figure out
on facebook
where's the views because you're not i
don't think it's because you're not
logged in
it's so annoying yeah
i'm making meats now smoking these meats
here
can i log into something real fast like
can someone make me a [ __ ] facebook
account that anyone
here i'll make one right now you guys
excited don't you know
screen now
it's just going to be the same thing do
you uh do you not want to what do you
want
me to look around i'm [ __ ]
no we do not please enter your email or
phone no don't please don't
you want me to make one and then i could
let you know
yeah give me get make one and then give
me the login id
because i want i want to be on facebook
i haven't logged into facebook in like
seven in years meantime let's see how
active he is
you cannot i can't see anything well
they're showing me something
can i see the photos it's a tease
oh look they did this photo and this
photo
which one do you like better
angry birds
um
[Music]
i just you know it we're at 32 minutes
we uh
we are the sponsors so but let's see
facebook so he's making a [ __ ] load of
money re-uploading his videos on
facebook but i'm dying to know so let's
do the ads and then just kind of gross
to me because you see like
the reaction on jeff's video
yeah and that's kind of what
i would expect from david or anymore
considering that he's the one
orchestrating everything like i would
think it would take this
time to like self
reflect and learn about himself and not
figure out how to make money right now
that's the problem i had with david's
apology which everybody apparently
keemstar gave it a standing
ovation
it was pretty good you know on surface
level yeah but what he's not starting
like that's not exaggerating like he
he stood up and gave him yes right well
who's watching it
somebody can attest to that somebody
told me that i don't want to get it
wrong
anybody has any anybody watching uh i'm
proud to say
that nobody none of our people watching
somebody told me that who was it
i'm sorry about the podcast keemstar
gave david's apology a standing ovation
oh i don't know okay um maybe maybe it
was
but what he's not a joke but maybe what
he but what he's not saying which
jeff finally does says is that three
months after this event happened
david received a text detailing
and graphic account and what happened
about it and continue to make those same
jokes about calm
silently remove the video and let
everyone else make a fool of themselves
exactly so save your apology and i'm
team trisha on that one now
it's just that you know like he's
apologizing and it was a better one
so it's like you don't want to just
dismiss it
because it is progress but
this is kind of gross to me a little bit
that is like already figure out
he's very he's figuring out the next on
facebook
and it's like he's posting the same
content it's not exactly like
brad did you see this five days ago 22
million views
buying views no dude that's david dobrik
facebook is crazy like that what is this
uh
what is this here tana mangu
photo with dumb dirt day holding up a
baby
with the cat i can't read because it's
so far away
aged like milk tana and dom
holding up a baby with the caption me
dom and the girl he brought home
to hook up with that night oh
bro gross that is not
okay wait i gotta step away for a minute
that is so disgusting
uh i'm gonna close the picture
are we really making jokes about him
[ __ ] babies
oh yeah whose baby is that i will i'd be
pissed if someone
if that was my baby well
but whose baby is that um probably a
family member
but this is what jeff was saying like
they all kept making those jokes
thinking that it's a character
i mean well even still that's really not
a good joke it's not but
it's just looking at it now knowing what
we know now
is disgusting okay so i tried to make
two facebooks
with my two different emails didn't work
so i had to use my phone number
i'm gonna send it to you just please uh
okay i'll log well let's do the ads
let's do that
let's do the ads now that we've looked
at that meme that will be scorched in my
eyes forever
all right ready hit me with some spicy
ass ad music
you feel that i'm catching a vibe
who are we talking about viori
it's a brand new performance apparel
it's perfect if you are sick and tired
of traditional
old workout gear everything is designed
to work out in but it doesn't feel or
look like it dan you want to show off
because you're wearing a pair
you might you might showing off
let's see it i don't have an angle no
well come stand behind us then
because dan got a pair of these and he's
freaking loving it
and also your girlfriend got a pair too
you hey
i walked down here and you're like do
these pants rule pants are nice
i mean hello so freaking comfortable
you're gonna want to wear them all the
time
in or out of the gym thank you damn the
product is
extremely versatile it can be used for
any activity like running
training yoga it's also great for
lounging
or weekend errands or gaming am i right
then
that's right boy would you game in those
oh i've gained i've gained
so hard in this there you have it i'm
working as a producer
what is viori ela vyori means
mountain because it rep i'm reading this
verbatim
because it represents it represents the
view
from the summit the expanse of clarity
that can
provide the awe-inspiring experience it
brings
wow now that's a [ __ ] pan
listen it's incredibly versatile and
comfortable it's designed to look great
every day
in or out of the gin it's perfect for
any workout
activity what can i say
and dan loves it i haven't tried them
yet but dan is a [ __ ] fan
[Music]
and dan doesn't like many things no i
hate most things yeah
how we uh it's super easy
to shop their website in fact [ __ ] it
let's go to their website what do i care
viori
[Music]
fiori pants
men's athletic wear look at this [ __ ]
you want to see what we're talking about
probably look at this guy big pimping
out there he's standing on top of a
mountain just like they said
so they got the color kind of just
floating in front of him
hands basically here's here's what
here's the offer
most comfortable most versatile
gym couch
game jogging it's pants for life
let's check out the women's wear
look at that yoga pose couldn't do that
in any pants could you
hit it with them regular hit it hit it
hit it all right you get the idea
it's perfect
all right the ori is an investment in
your happiness
for our listeners they are offering 20
off your first purchase
go get yourself some of the most
comfortable and versatile clothing on
the planet
earth at v o u r e
dot com slash h3 viori
that's v u o r e dot com slash
h3 oh say it one more time i think you
you spelled it wrong
v-u v here we go one more time now
let's don't forget the last time this is
the real one v-u-o-r-e
no that's literally what i'm reading
eli you read it's an i that is an i not
an e
oh go ahead you read it
it's b u o o
r
[Laughter]
uh but we said it so many times this has
got to be good at the
wrong time let's all say it together on
three
okay ready u o
r i dot com slash
and i'm gonna do it one more time so
they don't make me do a make good
and that's v u o
r i dot com slash h3
not only will you receive 20 off your
first purchase
but enjoy free shipping on any us
orders over 75 dollars and free returns
so that's the deal go to viori.com
h3 and discover the versatility
of viori clothing
[Music]
how long was that it's like a 20 minute
average
this folks is why you don't do live ad
reads especially with me
i tried to get you to do it we did them
we did them we did it i mean
you know i did my best please guys if
you want to support the show go buy some
of their pants so they don't get
mad at me they are very comfortable i
i'm not bullshitting i i'm
enjoying them very well walk down and
dan goes these pants these were pants i
can't believe it well it wasn't um
well i'll re-enact what you said reenact
what you said to me
i don't remember exactly i don't think i
i ambushed you with it though
i think it came up organically it came
up organically in the conversation
because we're talking about the sponsors
of the day
dan is a fan okay the next sponsor
don't tell trisha's adam and eve
[Music]
what you doing tonight girl
[Music]
this episode of h3 after dark is brought
to you by adam and eve
free stuff is awesome but free stuff to
spice up your bedroom is
even better select any of
select any one item from 50 off
did i read that right sorry i'm having
like a super dyslexic day
select almost any one item for 50
off and adam and eid eve will load you
up
with free stuff what does free stuff
mean
you'll have to find out
it doesn't say just says free stuff
it's probably good enter code
after dark at checkout and get 10
tantalizing free gifts i'm talking a
sexy item for him
a special gift for her and a third item
for both of us like a double-sided dildo
we could both utilize that a little less
to ask hilo love me daddy
has to ask move on
[Laughter]
all that and set six free
spicy movies i'm talking what i think
that means is deep
physical dvds physical media
hopefully you have a dvd player
and all that and it's still free
shipping
that's after dark eight well do you guys
know how to spell that first let's make
me spell it
a-f-t-e-r-d-a-r-k
after dark use offer code after dark at
checkout at adamandeve.com and get your
hands
on all of this free stuff and one item
from
all of their stores i'm talking but this
is what i've learned from trisha
butt plugs nipple clamps [ __ ] rope
like you could goddamn get like
futuristic like robot robocop
toys to go up there and bust crime in
your vagina
all for 50 off i'm saying just go check
it out
see what's out there to offer go to
adamandeve.com
and use the code after dark for 50
off and get 10 free gifts
wow what an offer for one item
yeah well the other shit's free thank
you guys
oh god are we gonna have any sponsors
left
[Music]
i'm having an off day i'm loopy
on a scale of one to ten how likely do
you think these sponsors
are to return dan i think it was i think
it was fine
oh you do yeah oh thank you guys
i'm super loopy today man i've had a
hell of a week
it's been a lot what were we talking
about oh i wanted to get into facebook
do we have a facebook login now
maybe yes i sent it to you all right
i am not going to talk to you yeah don't
do it on screen
i won't put it on screen um okay yes dan
are you just logging in to look at the
views again
i just want to know what the [ __ ]
going on you know look around okay i'm
taking this
so it's just your phone number which i
will grab from discord
oh don't show on screen
login okay i've got his login
top secret you can't see anything i'm
doing right no i'm not showing
anything why is it all creepy it sounded
like nice wedding music and then
there's like creepy music
i like this because i guess there was
some creepy music underneath that clock
who knows if you're gonna talk save here
okay
i am logged in good job
i'm in thank you ab thank you baby
[Applause]
so this is interesting now that we're in
look david's vlogs
this is from one day ago okay
so now how do i see the views how do i
click like this
i mean i'm serious it does facebook
doesn't make any sense
i see comments and shares why you lot
where do i see the videos i just spent
all this time to log in
can you tell me where the views are i
don't know i know i don't
it probably doesn't show on here i don't
know somebody showed it
facebook [ __ ] sucks videos
dude facebook is such a dumpster fire i
literally
hate love you're young how do i look at
the [ __ ] views
oh here they are here they are latest
see this is six days ago five million
views
yeah the views are wild oh he this was a
justin bieber one
so he's re-uploading his bangers like
justin bieber and probably making a [ __ ]
load of money
it's kind of epic don't you think he
wanted to kick his ass he probably put
up a fight
i mean
that's so shameless it's like he's
trying to cash in
before this guys will also tell them
they don't want to
appear in the videos oh they're right
well also he knows facebook doesn't give
a [ __ ] about anything
he could be he could be uploading like
he could be uploading like uh execution
vid
like isis execution videos and facebook
wouldn't care
why would he do that but it's just kind
of my point
google some isis videos what what
anyway so he's still out there doing the
taking
out of context david is still crushing
it on facebook
what else we got we have got um
oh this was something i just absolutely
had to discuss
it came to my attention that there are
some
sick mother lovers out there who have i
guess it's not surprising seeing it is
the internet
that people are going to jason nash's
kids
instagram pages who are
uh 15 and 12
and leaving hateful comments
why exactly why would you do that no
i i'm i'm hoping and praying that none
of the foot soldiers are
participating in such horrid
horrid behavior but let's these kids
have
first of all enough and and this goes
for any of these people's family members
yeah that have nothing to do with this
this is not
an okay behavior i made a tweet about it
i said if you're commenting on jason
nash's children's instagrams post
you are a piece of [ __ ] stop his kids
and all their family members have
nothing to do with this
don't be like that it's unacceptable and
gross i'm begging you to please stop now
these are young children
don't [ __ ] do this
and that goes for any of these people's
family members i mean
i was not happy about that
neil do you have anything to say it's
just not right
but that's the internet for you
can't say i'm surprised it's like
but like imagine leaving a hate comment
like a five-year-old's page
it's like i mean
she's a little older than that but yeah
either way it's no excuse
yeah there's no excuse it's just insane
i believe she's around 11 or 12. i mean
they obviously have nothing to do with
any of this of course
okay and again just because there's so
much coming out i know you guys
this is really good i'm sorry but i'm
still going
ela you're gonna love this i promise
this is okay we've got a gardener
situation here
this is one of these things that's going
to blow your guys's minds okay
i took a pic this morning and it oh you
saw a look
oh i wanted to surprise you with it i
didn't read the whole thing but
yeah okay so this is the consent form
when dom sleeps with girls he makes them
sign
ndas allegedly first first first i want
you to notice
that how much there are he's got stacks
of this [ __ ]
you know that's like 30 right there
easily
okay vin diesel's like oh
man so this girl said anyone remember
seeing signing these
dirty doms and dirty doms apartment i
looked through my snap stories
because i remember there were sexual
consent forms and i always wondered if
they're
serious or joke well we know now
now when you read it i was wondering so
is this in connection to
it being a part of david's videos or
that's just
dom's personal ndas that he gives to
girls i have heard
that allegedly
these were given out to any women who
slept with members of the vlog squad
i don't know if this is just something
dom did though
they were found in dom's apartment but
the terminology in here is gonna make
you scream
okay get ready
i blank hereby declare under penalty of
perjury that i am over 18 years old
penalty of perjury how about just look
at her id
dumb [ __ ] also it's called sexual
consent
form how is someone going to consent to
have sex if they're not
he's like dude that's not how it works
that's what i was i saw in the comments
on this
thread they're like well if they're not
18 then this
whole document is not valid
that just goes to show you how many
people he slept with who are right on
that cusp
could be 15 could be 19. it's all good
i further declare that this agreement is
of my own free will
and that neither i nor any other near
i nor any near or dear to me
has been threatened with harm or
embarrassment
who wrote about this jesus well right
off the bat
literally the first thing it says under
penalty of perjury it's not it
you're not under oath signing this
[ __ ] nda in his apartment what the
[ __ ] are they talking about
but what is what does this mean he says
i am signing this and i nor anyone near
or dear which is not a legal term by the
way
has been threatened with harm or
embarrassment is that is that suggesting
possibly that like he's
they're trying to declare that they're
not being exploited
into doing it uh willingly signing this
right
like it's not like if you don't sign
this i'm gonna
kill you okay what the
[ __ ] now stay tuned because my favorite
part's at the end i promise
both parties agree that this is a
private agreement
not to be disclosed to third parties
except in case of
accusations of misconduct s misconduct
by the agreeing party if he she shows
us if he she shows
or makes public this agreement without
accusations
it is agreed that they will be liable
for damages of invasion of privacy this
was written by a lit
by a [ __ ] idiot
this person can't even pretend to have
legal training
[Laughter]
i found a tweet that said that he copied
it straight from google images
love let me see that yeah i would not be
surprised
yeah that's a joke
okay so by initialing
i agree to engage in all or some
of the following consensual acts you
ready
okay sexual fondling and kissing
sure i feel like those could be two
separate categories
i feel like kissing and sexual funding
fondling because this is so awkward he's
like okay he goes
oh dude bro oh my god
just imagine before sexual encounter
like
here's okay pen also you know they're
already like drunk
get ready for the next [ __ ] penetration
vaginally or anal with penis
also he didn't he didn't a complete
width he did a dash
for the sake of brevity apparently what
is it a tweet
uh with penis fingers or any
toy slash body parts so that includes
foot
body parts oh then oral
copulation mutual mutual of course
and then another oral copulation
unilateral
wait what what does that mean i'm not
i didn't really understand it means it's
just going one way they're basically
clarifying
both 69 and just getting a blowy
those are both fine right i'm going to
come
oh and then he has a
and then he leaves in a space to you
know
uh if there's any other comments he
definitely
wrote this himself i mean allegedly not
definitely
other consexual sexual conduct to be
specified so they'd be like okay baby so
let's see what do you think we're going
to do tonight japanese rain goggles
dirty sanchez
red wings i'm going to be taking a [ __ ]
on your chest okay we're going to write
we're going to fill that in down here
cleveland steamer you know
so okay now get ready this is my
favorite part i've not gotten to my
favorite part yet
really not even close just you're going
to freak when you're here i know
i further declare that i am at this time
not under influence of alcohol drugs or
medication
and agree to engage in this consensual
act
get ready hold on to your [ __ ] hats
at this time i do not intend to change
my mind before the sex
act or acts are over however
if i do it is further understood
that when i say the word code red
my partner agrees to instantly stop
oh my god so so just to be clear stop
this i'm not uncomfortable stop
that's not the right verbiage the
correct verbiage is to scream
cold red
cold red ladies and gentlemen so i feel
like
there it had to be just him or a friend
because
no lawyer would have whatever signed him
bro if you sent this to a lawyer
they would be like you cannot give this
to anyone you do understand that they'd
be like have you given this to anyone
yet they'd be like okay we need to
gather all of these
if possible and bring them back and
incinerate them
um code red so if anyone out here is
listening and they want to know
how to stop it's could be called we can
call it a code red
i think i read i also made a funny tweet
thank you very much i like to call
myself out don't hate me
i make funny tweets my hi my name's
ethan klein and i make 23s
i said in response girl says
stop stop dumb she didn't say code red
give me some skin for that it's funny
high five you i mean the topic is kind
of serious i don't feel like high fiving
you
but it's funny it's funny stop
you didn't say code red you remember
what we agreed to in the agreement
you clear we clearly wrote in that i'd
be [ __ ] on your back
and the extra addendum
addendum thank you though called red
code red
all right are you even just imagining
that go red go red yeah it's so romantic
deepak
oh my god i can't this story just keeps
getting crazier
is there something you guys wanted me to
watch in the discord i haven't been
following
no just i found a video where the forum
is shown
but it's only shown for a second and
they don't discuss it it's just like in
passing they show it
they show what the forum he says there's
really
the form interview i have no i have no
problem believing this because i was
wondering what if this is made up
that i made up code radical
it's just so dumb it's almost hard to
believe you know
not stop called right
you have to play this sound if you want
to stop
[Music]
[Laughter]
stop i'm very uncomfortable dog
let's do make the sound
[Laughter]
oh no you believe this [ __ ]
yes and no and poor jeff had to come out
and like you know
defend this guy knowing that
david received a letter saying this guy
this guy dom is really people say why
why is
jeff getting all the hate and not dom my
answer to that is like
everybody knows dom there's no question
about dom
i mean that yeah i'm sure that he is
it's just that
oh yeah dom is [ __ ] because jeff spoke
then there's more like what's happening
with that well also people like jeff
myself included now i'm just i say that
because i didn't know him
but there i feel like there's a
redemption arc for jeff and so
there's the conversation around someone
like jeff is much more interesting where
dom it's like
like you know bye forever
you're done
code red please stop
stop
so interestingly that document doesn't
say anything about
alcohol being involved it did it said
it says at the time of signing this you
have to be sober okay yeah but what if
you're too drunk to remember code red
well on forge you know like then you're
[ __ ] out of luck
well what his expert
legal document fails to take into place
is that you can remove consent
or at some point of being too drunk not
be able to consent
right in which case you need to go
it's a cod red
you guys want to move on to my next
favorite topic
[Music]
you know how we do it around here what
else you got
what should we title this oh no oh no
oh no
hey hey let me ask you something
what sound would a small boy make the
moment he walked into james charles
house
yep that's the correct answer
in fact we need to sell that device
so you can just right
so people know that should just be our
apps
i want to sell the device that
just cycles between james shows going oh
no
can you play that for me zach i wanna
hear this wanna hear this side by side
[Laughter]
oh no what okay okay here let me ask you
something
zach what does james charles say
when he hears the code red
oh no that's it
[Music]
there's some really funny james charles
news what should we call this title i
feel like we should put a title up on it
already
discussing after the episode why i like
these meta discussions
what what maybe we call it you already
know
you already know what it is oh is ian
gone oh no
oh no no no no no
no yes his internet died i'm sure he'll
be back whenever it comes back
how about this forgiving jeff
burying david
bearing's deep ms dog let's not say
bearing
yeah we fight i like forgiving
that's nice yeah we like forgiveness
[Laughter]
forgiving jeff
hmm yeah maybe we'll think about it
afterwards
shame all right jade this is this is a
really good james charles news i swear
to god
this has just been a really good
good [ __ ] james charles first of all
tells a fan to text them we love that
deaf noodles shout out as always
guys you don't even need to watch my
show just follow jeff's noodles
the sky's the [ __ ] wait are you showing
his phone
no no no no it's a it's like a
commercial number
okay okay i think well it's in his story
so
oh james charles asks fan to text him
this is less than a month after james
confessed to sexting minors
in the last six months five of james
fans exposed him for allegedly
solicitating
nudes and pressuring them to do the same
three of them were minors there's been
five yeah i don't even realize oh my god
this is the t
so here's james he's but you know so the
thing about these like commercial
numbers
is that he has the he can still vet
them and respond to them
so it goes hi sisters tell me your
measurement your size how much armpit
hair you have and maybe i'll get back to
you sister
you remember how he's in the armpit hair
hi sisters respond with a picture of
your armpit hair and i'll maybe get back
to you
hi sisters hit him with the
code red please act
keep your hand on that button all
episode
yeah so
i feel like he's probably gonna pick up
a few young boys this way
yeah and that definitely makes me feel
let me call it let's call the number and
see what happens no it's not
it's it's one of those community numbers
it's just it just puts you on a
marketing list that's all it does
oh [ __ ] really yeah yeah don't do it i'm
coming
it's just going to take you to a
voicemail of him i guess it might be
funny to hear that
yeah fair enough eight i wish i didn't
have to use my number but
hey [ __ ] it let's listen i got it
can you hear okay yeah yeah okay
you just [ __ ] answer it says i'm
texting y'all back right now am i
supposed to text
well says text me sisters
who calls boomer hi sisters charles here
and thanks for calling my phone number
my voicemail box is currently full but
you should definitely
send me a text i'll reply right away
with a link to sign
up so you can receive exclusive messages
from me you'll be the first to know
about new videos
photos merch sales events and you may
even get a selfie or two
oh no we don't have blocks
oh no oh no
should i text it code red
should i oh i'm gonna text him a picture
of my armpit and see if he responds
because he won't be able to tell 3-1-0
905. then you just call this number
right you're right all right
well these are my phones are so annoying
okay recent
okay here it is
[Music]
how do i make it look like i'm a boy
though okay boomer
i need it to look like i'm uh i needed
to look like i'm a fertile young man
okay boomer like that maybe
does that look good either too much hair
that one doesn't look too hairy
that looks pretty good here click the
photos click the photo
wait wait you can see our background
right right
yeah yeah yeah you need to retake oh you
can crop it okay here
no let me take it
wait do it again because you can see my
face
or make it as youthful as possible
good what's happening here
like that perfect
people like sing button oh that's sexy
now let me add like an emote or here
i'll do i'll draw a heart or something
don't you want to know if he's going to
respond or you just watch to someone
just walking
on you wait how do i draw mother why am
i such a boomer ass [ __ ] i want to do a
heart
well why didn't you ask him how to do
emojis
why is it so thin it's like
so thin sister slacking
[Music]
okay okay can i show this i want to show
you guys the picture
be careful about showing your phone
screen
i'm gonna take a screenshot send it in
the discord
okay i'm gonna save the photo and i'm
gonna attach this to my text message
to the one and only
by the way you know he's gonna get dick
pics and stuff he said send me pictures
and you might get yourself a joke
but i need to crop it sorry guys it's
important
[Music]
i'm sure everybody understands
people aren't mad right i mean this is
important
[Music]
okay i got it cropped perfectly
okay here we go i'm sending it
sent
okay i'm going to send you dan the photo
i sent
yeah this is good
i think this might be a chance he
responds
maybe he can tell i'm a little bit older
right yeah it's not really his style
okay here show him what i sent all right
one sec
sister sister
sister someone else do me this challenge
hello
you you email him or text him to just
say hi i love you i love you i love you
i'm six a 16 male or whatever see if he
responds
let's go okay you got it here open it on
discord
does that make sister sense it does make
sense
since you guys think this is going to
work
probably not
the heart the hair is his thing no he
did he said he wanted to see
hairy armpit
you think he wanted a twink armpit i
mean i guess i just would have assumed
but maybe you're right
with the age cohort he's going to wait
okay cool wait i didn't
pop the bottom well you screenshotted it
on your phone that's what you sent me
okay i did crop it when i sent it to you
also do you think it helps that there's
like several attempts
such a boomer ass [ __ ]
sister
hi sister did you text him maybe
that should be him i'm hi sisters
you want to craft a text together
that should be your nfts anyone want to
buy that
nft you know they're cracking up by that
[ __ ]
just type like hi sister i love you i'm
16 am and i've
got and i'm uh whatever ah you tell us
what you write you do it
you can't keep getting i've spent too
much time already
on this uh so anyway that's him
now next up james charles is starting a
podcast
called get this i swear to [ __ ]
i swear to [ __ ] it's called this fresh
and young
you're making that up you think so
you think i'm making that up
oh it's called good and fresh okay okay
that's pretty that's definitely
different
that's their friends
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i would
[Laughter]
okay but it is called good and fresh
i said i've been compromised because i
text i texted before you corrected
yourself i said hi sister i am young and
fresh and then i put correction i mean
how do i watch young and fresh but
it's not called young and fresh hi i'm
young and fresh
come on baby he's not answering that
oh god i cannot his smirk
you guys want to hear my bomb tweet
um so but hold on when you wrote you
tweet were you thinking
no i knew the title okay i said look i
just was remembering it wrong
looks like james charles is starting his
own podcast called good and fresh
it's perfect title because it also
describes his pref his perfect sexual
partner
i heard their first guest is woody allen
they should have a lot to talk about
nice crickets tweets are always really
funny when you learn
all right well listen i'm not relenting
on james that dude
i what i should have said is you it's a
great title but i think what you should
have called it is
is is uh young young and fresh
that would have been that probably just
better
anyway there's more james oh i know
i know but it's good oh no
aren't we having fun
okay a great meme james charles when he
takes the wrong beauty gummy
these are his subs you remember how many
subjects james charles sucks the wrong
beauty gummy for hair
james charles admitting to exchanging
nudes with a child
all right anyway i can't wait to listen
to his uh
young and fresh podcast
another james charles meme i swear to
god i'm not stopping
wait oh okay so so
james charles interestingly does seem to
be um
facing some some backlash on what's
going on his controversy
once again cat 10 barge the legend
i don't know anything about this maybe
you guys do but there was a youtube
series called ins
instant influencer you guys know about
this show
i do not it appears to be a youtube
original
uh that starred james charles
i'm assuming it was a reality show based
off of the images i'm seeing where he
was like the lead judge
it seems to me like a top model top
designer
kind of thing you know top chef right
yeah yeah
so season two was renewed but guess
who's not hosting this time
james stratton youtube kicked him off
his own show
love to see it oh my god this is
challenging hello
i do not like james he is a predator one
good
thing but and that includes this portion
of
the vlog squatting game stronger
i was just gonna say that it's it's nice
that
um it's nice that youtube is finally
like
doing things taking a stand saying
something
because they don't usually do anything
yeah they usually wait until the
basically the whole
ecosystem of youtube is on the brink of
total
annihilation but again i said it last
time and i
feel like i should say it again going
into our next story
is that the way that logan handled his
massive controversy makes me appreciate
him more compared to what david's doing
yeah which is basically still
re-uploading his videos on facebook and
monetizing them
love that yep anyway
we have uh you guys aren't gonna believe
it but wendy williams has farted again
no i swear to god dan wendy williams has
farted again are you ready zach
oh yeah okay you guys aren't gonna
believe this
what is going on with her
she must have some kind of condition i
don't know
with peace and love you know i mean i
hope she's okay but
she's on a show well here's the first
one you're old enough to understand
political correctness in the times that
we live
now you can't get over there people on
the board you know
she's working right from a man to a
woman or a woman to a man
but you can't even do that locker room
thing that cop wasn't playing that
i mean you're lucky you only got now
we've i said go ahead and hit him with
the isolated
part that crazy okay
second one happened recently she farted
and burped at the same time fantastic
stuff looks like
new boyfriend we haven't caught anybody
coming out of the house yet but you know
just a matter of time she's not lonely
i apologize i apologize oh she's not
lonely
go ahead zach
[Laughter]
come on people that doesn't get better
than that
well oh ian is back just in time oh ian
welcome back we're just reviewing
wendy williams third fart
breaking news
this one apparently is a fart or a snort
burp i'll be honest with you
it's pretty wild let's like slow down
it's okay
move
what the [ __ ] was that
i can't wait let me go back cause
come on yeah
oh with her mouth say how you doing look
at the
audience members be enough to understand
wait look at that the first time i met
him you know he was um
in think like a man one and i and joelle
reminded me of this
too this morning every time he used to
come here to our show
i would always say if i wasn't married
if he wasn't married
that's my kind of guy you know like
taller how you doing
love it enough to handle me and fluffy
enough
to understand let's go out for good food
look at that
and and funny in a corny cool way calm
down
but but groan and then she's talking
about she wants to [ __ ] with this guy
and then i don't know what he's doing
now but it is never too early to jump
back in the game
and
[Music]
yeah how you doing because you'll find
that when you get divorced
later on in life i don't know about you
but i don't want
anything going like i'm back in the game
immediately
immediately and then the virus happened
so i just slow down it's okay where did
we pass it
no
[Laughter]
okay again i'm not quite sure what i
heard
zach
okay okay okay wait oh wait let me focus
now we can't laugh because i really want
to listen
okay go ahead zach
wait did you cut it early because i feel
like there was more noise after the oop
okay okay now can you slow it down a
little bit
okay now can we get a symphony of all
of the wendy's sounds yeah
[Laughter]
no not to be controversial but i think
that's a snort
right it didn't sound like a fart not a
fart
the best is that laughs like what yeah
so i'm calling out all musicians who are
really good at making digital music to
you know i want that beat
i know there's like a dope ass beat
somewhere there between all those sounds
yeah definitely so i'm calling all that
calling all you guys out
wait play it all
i love the hoop
that origin i mean i got to say the
original yeah i don't think
anything like i mean people don't
believe us when they say that's the real
isolated sound
it is 150 the real isolators like here's
can you do because i know there's
doubters in there
play the original one on
play the original one unboosted and then
play the boo
thurs wendy williams yeah there's wendy
williams
she's leading a whole and she calls it a
fart gate like i'm
sorry bart gate no what's what's next
911 was it inside
you know what i mean like come on
okay
it kind of makes me like her it's like
wait play it and the original sound
oh he probably doesn't have that on the
sound board you're talking about like
from the show
yeah well yeah
okay because so all you wendy william
fart truthers need to [ __ ]
get a grip 27 years old with the amount
of misinformation out in the world we
need to get
the facts the grades gotta get it right
and political correctness in the times
that we live now
you can't just slap people on the booty
yeah of course he probably knows it's
not right from a man to a woman or a
woman to a man
but you can't even do that locker room
thing that cop wasn't playing that
i mean you're lucky
okay we all heard it wow i definitely
heard it isolate it
boost it yeah
come on ladies and gentlemen the jury
i think i rest my case on wendy williams
anyway that's that i wanted to ask you
guys
you know after all of our nft adventures
we all got
we all got paid out some nice coinage
what's everybody done with their coins
because i see eth uh
ethereum's dropped a bit let me check it
where it's at right now
ethereum right now is down
it's down a little bit not too bad so
what what did you guys all do do you
guys sell are you holding
i'm holding holding two
i sold two as well good luck chatter out
ian i'm holding hold on
baby oh yeah
i was like what's i was like what is
cryptocurrency i'm selling this
the reason i sold is because i saw that
it was at like a peak and based on what
i've seen at crypto it's always like
yeah
well we're all rich and then it's like
oh it's worthless
so i got it i think that over time
though it's gonna go up it's not
you shouldn't check it every day exactly
i i was saying we should keep some but
ethan was like well then you make your
own digital wallet
and i was like okay i'm out
no i know i didn't mean that we could
have kept it in the same digital wallet
i wasn't trying to like beef with you
well i did not feel like having to mess
with anything
well because i wanted the i wanted to
give it all like on because i was
thinking like i
i think having a bitcoin would be good
and i think this and that but i'm not
actually i don't actually want to get
into all that yeah she goes ethan i want
you to buy bitcoin i was like
we'll make a wallet and buy a bitcoin no
what the [ __ ]
my wife still doesn't believe in me
ela apparently but the real reason i
wanted to take it out is because this
passover which is a secret to any of my
family listening
switches on sunday is it customary to
give gifts out on passover
no not really you don't need to oh what
hold on
isn't it say what zack the offi common
like the kids find them
oh yeah there's their pokemon oh that's
yeah well we don't really
like hide it and then the kid who finds
it gets it hey
wait is it yom kippur where you give
gifts no absolutely not
which is the one you give gives hanukkah
not only hanukkah
no in israel you buy [ __ ] like bed
sheets
um i think that's like september-ish
yeah so well anyway during this dinner
um uh that nobody knows about i cashed
out all of our bitcoins and we're gonna
and i want not bitcoins but yeah we
don't have right the ethereum
and i wanted to present a um
nice present to all my family based on
all this funny money we made yeah yeah
any of those family mm-hmm yeah yeah
so i'm sorry what
was that and ironically enough guess
who's going to be
there trisha
hopefully will not be um it's her first
passover huh
is it for seder she's going to want to
lead she thinks she's like they do
next week she's going to lead
she'll start arguing with people about
what things mean
the parsley what is the parsley
okay oh another big news
zach are you moving out i'm anthony's
song i'm moving out
whoa
proud of you what's the deal worth what
situation
or i guess what's the address
i found an apartment um wow
i'm super stoked uh it's available
april 14th and um
already buying furniture wow april 14th
so that's what like two like uh like two
weeks just over two weeks
and may i ask what part of town you're
moving into no don't well you shouldn't
don't ask them what area
no no just don't what uh remember that
we've
been getting swatted every day what area
why let me ask you this okay let me ask
you this
are you moving closer to the city um
it's still in the valley okay yeah all
right setting up roommates
housemates not one bedroom
good for you man i think you're going to
love it
i'm very excited um and
i i mean it's a new journey and yeah
i'm looking forward to it are you scared
to move out of your parents house a
little bit
uh i mean there's a little there's
qualms with it you know
but i i think it's time i think it's
time
are your parents supportive of your
decision they actually are
oh actually yeah yeah they're um they're
actually very supportive of it you know
waiting so i could get the [ __ ] out well
you know
you know obviously they're sad because
you know leaving the ass but
um yeah they're they're like we cannot
be with furniture
or you know whatever so cool you know
what they're planning to do with your
room are they going to turn into like uh
a sublet
i heard they're turning into a sex
dungeon but
shout out to todd
[Laughter]
are you worried at all um let me do you
eat a lot of your mom's cooking are you
worried about the
like that you're just gonna be eating
out a lot does your mom cook for you a
lot
um no i actually i mean she cooks for me
um but
i i make my own meals like i'm actually
a pretty good cook
um yeah interesting excuse me
interesting
yeah so a lot of chicken a lot of steak
uh you know
that kind of stuff well that's
terrific news that congratulations thank
you
all right now we come to basically
the the sounds of war
wait what we haven't been at war for the
whole first like hour and a half
no the sounds of war come up now
uh okay play the war silence i was just
trying to get
people from the beginning do you hear
the call
my warriors
[Applause]
foot soldiers are simple 9 11.
wake up wake up wake up
now is the time
you hear that
do you okay thank you you're gonna see
the power of god
[Applause]
wait play the horns again semen
makes miss semen
makes milk tastes great
semen is just another type of
tastes milk you know starbucks put semen
in their milk
frankin semen is a good idea
all right kill the music burning in
their butthole
all right here's the problem i've got
huge problem so interestingly
mike maljak matt magelack
faith banks and keemstar
did a podcast together here's the
biggest twist
not mad at keemstar
how is that possible but i always knew
face banks was a was a utter [ __ ]
idiot
oh god but now i literally have
actual proof that this guy is operating
on what could only be
you know perceived as single
digit brain cell capacity
okay you want to know why
why yeah
take a step back okay here's what here's
what face banks by the way who has
credible accusations of essay against
him
who is a menace society who's been in
fights
like you remember that whole thing at
the bar where he was like
trying to like it's like the dude is a
literal degenerate
i mean mike's in it i mean zac we know
how zack feels about mike
he be [ __ ] his gym shorts yeah
enough said that's all you have to say
and we have proof of that that's not
even
that's not even defamation we've seen
[ __ ] we've seen him shoot his fans
i've seen him [ __ ] his gym shirt
parody parody no no no no we've
already we've seen it
i thought nobody's gonna assume can you
imagine suing me for defamation
your honor he clearly has not seen
you're daring him too because here's the
thing
during discovery he'll have to turn over
all of his underwear
prove that there's no [ __ ] stains on any
of his underwear
i followed him into a 24-hour fitness
and i can confirm that he's [ __ ] his
gym shorts
wow okay that might be defamatory
parody all minecraft in my minecraft
anyway listen to these [ __ ] frat bros
emotions out of it and just like what
could this be
like i'm
right i mean not
really because she knows them yeah and
she's in the video wasn't she in the
[Music]
lgbt
we have this issue where is this not
because
you don't have the new computer yet or
is this some other [ __ ]
all right we have a shitty laptop we
should replace this
what's that zach dan get that mayo
zach uh or sorry ian say that again
dan get that mayo
whoa what does mayo have to do with
anything
i don't see ian's lips moving
ian did you say dan get that mail
[Music]
what did you say i'm stroking [ __ ] down
here huh
he's a ventriloquist yeah
you heard of jeff dunham ian might like
that i've been chugging the water all
right are we good dan
all right let's assume these because i
thought i thought in the whole
all right let's listen to these frat
bros talk about basically
bruh just listen to [ __ ] the thing it
was like we're gonna refer to her as
hannah
yeah because of further work projects or
whatever they wanted to protect her
yeah okay i mean but we know who she is
like we can see her face
and obviously i say this listen um
we were talking about how ethan klein
and trisha paytas have
um a fat interest in seeing he's fat
i mean can you imagine that this guy how
old is faith
how old is he i'm gonna guess like 25.
yeah that would be my guess
too let's see just imagine that's how
you talk
29 okay yo ethan klein and issue bridge
have a fat
interest
doug what what universe do you live in
i'm going to take a step back so i'm
going to under a drinking age let me
clarify
uh so drunk and she completely passed
out
doesn't even remember the night and
basically while she was passed out she
claims that
dom raped her you know those are her
allegations so ours obviously we weren't
there
but yeah that's what we're referring to
now okay listen
i'm probably gonna get crucified for
even dancing
on this line but and i will say this if
i had to bet
my money on it and i'm also a man of the
facts i want to see what's going on like
i want to i want to know
what proof is there
i will i want to say this um the girl
who is accusing
can i pause it you're
mad at the facts and there there there's
there's all the fact like in terms of
any case of
essay can i just say there's never
proof of our word or essay like what
what proof do you want you want her to
stop him and say hey let me record
i'm listening obviously she wasn't
capable of even consenting
so of course there's not going to be
proof and by the way
usually in cases of essay because of
this
this like uh victim blaming mentality
that
faze banks the who's always on the side
of fat
facts i always need to get the fattest
fat
even in this case the facts are
so overwhelming yeah nobody's even
doubting i mean there's about as much
evidence as you could ever have
yeah like i don't even see anyone trying
to even discredit her because it's
simply so overwhelming
i don't know if the facts qualify as fat
though
as soon as i heard him talk about proof
i was like no
tell me i didn't hear that
david and everybody of this whole night
the victim
right is completely anonymous right no
can you just learn before you talk i
want to get the facts
straight so before you get the fat facts
straight what do you go i mean it's the
same thing jeff did
it's like if you're gonna come out here
and talk about something so seriously
you should at least [ __ ] read about
it
they're not anonymous oh i'm sorry i
need to make a correction
there are no accusations of essay
against banks that's an important
correction it makes so
i take that back there's no uh credible
credible
there was accusations of assault
okay okay then he assaulted an ex
right no his his ex was sexually
assaulted uh allegedly
at a club when they were together but
not by him by someone else
by a security guard he was yeah he was
at a club and he
um i believe there's accusations of him
uh
attacking a girl or something along
those lines
oh yeah there was a lot of [ __ ] that
went down at that club but okay
but i correct the record i apologize
there's no credible allegations thank
you guys
okay good job ab for for correct me on
that one
peace and love with peace and loves
banks no accusation essay but i
both peace and love you are a [ __ ]
brain dead
vapid there are more brain cells in the
vacuum of outer
space than there are in your head
it's got a fat brain though fat
alright let's continue
it was like we're gonna refer to her as
hannah yeah because of further work
projects or whatever they want to
participate
it's a pseudonym to protect their
[ __ ] identity how
dumb are you he's like they're calling
they call her hannah
because it's a made-up identity and
that's fat facts
dude
this like victim or whatever
this suppose hannah supposedly hannah
yeah okay i mean but we know who she is
thank you
she can see her face and obviously i say
this listen
um thank you keemstar okay
we were talking about how ethan klein
and trisha paytas have
um a fat interest in
yo sound by we have a fat i am
i have a fat interest that's for sure i
can't stop eating
that's what you mean as far as having a
fat interest
in some other thing yeah
fried chicken wednesday baby yeah now
that's a bad interest
seeing these people fail for every
reason and just go down right
um if there was ever a vlog or there was
ever a piece of content that david made
that you could go and like a reverse
engineer and create some kind of story
out of
wouldn't it be this because of the
because of the
what are you talking about okay faye
okay banks
ricky ricardo okay let me call you ricky
you are more of a ricky
banks you know
let i mean the man
to actually go out there and be such a
[ __ ] in public
yeah okay first of all i'm re i'm i'm sp
me i'm fairly busy guy i am spending my
time
reverse engineering all of david's vlogs
let me also notice that he removed this
vlog a year and a half ago
why ricky fat
fat ricky because it was removed
the video was removed so that so how am
i supposed to reverse engineer a video
that was removed
and then ricky if i may call you a fat
brain ricky
fat you want you want to know a fat fact
it's because he got
a email from
hannah saying she was essayed and that's
why
they removed the video go ahead
okay let's go ahead with the [ __ ]
galaxy brain argument oh yeah
it's just it's food for thought i'm not
sick
i'm not saying this i'm not trying to
say anything
again this is the coward's way to make
any pathetic argument
i'm not claiming that ethan and tricia
are
are combing through every single david
dobrik blog ever made
by the way i i've never had a problem
with david i'm not saying
that the victim is lying but like this
alleged
is like anonymous or whatever and like
hannah whatever
is she i don't even think she exists
that's a fat [ __ ] yeah i love this guy
thinks that i'm just
like again i didn't have a problem with
david i literally
only learned about this when trisha
explained to me her history with david
dover because i knew she had this
history with him
[Music]
yes
because his [ __ ] brain is blank
and he's shooting blank bullets what's
better he's shooting blanks or his
head is blank i don't see why it can't
be both
yeah i like phase blanks you guys like
that i like the shooting blings
she looks good you shooting blanks love
that
fat blanks bretta like i said if i had
to bet my money on it
weird should happen it just seems like
weird [ __ ] happened not essay
not nothing she's probably exaggerating
if i had a bit if i
oh what kind of bet is that yeah what
kind of bet
if i had to bet my money weird [ __ ]
happen
okay not be specific about it no i i
hear i hear what you're saying
it's just it that it could yeah but
here's the the reason why
yeah i disagree back thank you keemstar
wow i'm about to become friends with
people
oh my god i never thought i would hear
that thing is [ __ ]
innocent thank you thank you
or whatever
i don't think he's i don't think he's i
don't think he's saying anything i'm
necessarily
just saying like this would be i'm
saying the correct
approach to situations like this is take
a step back
emotions out of it and just like what
could this be
like i don't know here's here's here's
the problem
you're not saying anything this is the
correct the correct way what is correct
way
is to let david continue to do his thing
no actually funnily enough again this
girl sent this message
to dom three months later you're not
familiar with the story
you're doing a dangerous disservice to
all of your listeners who are probably
all
young men who are you are and who are
you know no i think he has a lot of girl
audience too
and his mom's basement i don't know
about the i don't know about that
i don't know i think the banks guys the
phrase guys shooting blanks
they're shooting at the face means he's
impotent
that's what i thought you meant i wasn't
really sure what the other face blanks
either way whatever it is it's only bad
like
you're discrediting the victims and any
future victim that would think of coming
out well also the way that he framed all
of that
is he under the impression that you and
trisha like broke the story
like he doesn't even seem to understand
that this was like an investigation
like we we've just talked about on our
show this was cat that put this all
together
right we we had nothing it does sound
like that
i think he's under the impression that
like we i don't think
like he probably never read the article
i don't think he knows
any of the basic premises of anything
yeah and that's why we call him phase
blanks because his
space is basically a perfect void
you're very special do you know how hard
it is to create a perfect void
nasa goes to such lengths and expensive
experiments
to suck all particles out of a space to
create a perfect void
phase banks need to be studied by
science because his
his brain is such a perfect void you we
could conduct experiments inside of it
here's the problem there's a strange
dichotomy here okay
in the real world in the world as we
know it to exist
where where claims like this are brought
up in criminal court there's something
called the burden of proof
the burden of proof falls on the accuser
and the people who
provide uh charges against the person
claimed to have committed a crime
unfortunately some would say fortunately
that burden of proof does not exist on
the internet and so what happened
wrong this is not a ex this is not a
situation of cancer culture i mean the
article
had receipts for every single thing i
literally saw everything was backed out
with heaviness
i literally saw a picture of of dom come
out with a used condom
the same night in the same clothing
and a picture of her blackout drunk
being held up by her friends
i mean if they looked and read their
article they would see
that they were very
very demanding of the girl providing
as much evidence as possible and they
they decided
yeah oh they reported her of course she
did that reporter cat
there was no like there wasn't a moment
where you read
something and there was no evidence
provided or
listed that they received it you know
cat
did an absolutely amazing job of her
journalistic due diligence
everything was so well supported but the
thing is when you have such a perfect
void of a brain
you can't feel it with anything
otherwise it's not a perfect void
so he's holding on to that
phase of phase blanks ladies and
gentlemen
what happens is you can be cancelled via
headline you could be if trisha paytas
okay
if trisha paytas tomorrow decides you
know banks is the new target
if she put her cards together right now
she could make you
look like a [ __ ] bad person why are
you guys so scared
why are you guys so scared for yourself
maybe there is stuff to
to find out about you sound like yeah it
sounds like you're just being really
defensive because there is something
i mean no it doesn't work like that
things are backed up we're talking about
things that are backed up
otherwise the conversation will go
nowhere this is this is textbook
r word culture it's like nobody can ever
make
a claim and one by the way that says
credible it couldn't be more credible
than this
without people like these guys trying to
change it into this other conversation
of like
you could say anything about anyone yeah
like you could say something about me
tomorrow
oh really trisha peters could say all
kinds of things about me
man all the dirt she has on me
interesting because that wasn't my
reaction when i heard the story
certainly my reaction was that i felt
really bad for the victim i was really
upset
david you know it was about how is this
gonna hurt me yeah
what what is someone gonna do to me
tomorrow yeah
exactly
hit the red alert button quick
yeah that's what they're thinking
they're like also you gotta love that
it's such a boys club these three guys
are sitting there
talking about all this the voice of
reason so that should just tell you
something
yeah was that in that last little bit
that was actually mike talking
yeah that was mine thanks right but but
like so he also seems to be under the
impression that trisha
is the reason that all this is happening
that's what he just said yeah
it's like trisha can go on a podcast and
make something and say whatever which is
which is by the way i know this is like
we're auxiliary players in all of this
let me just take what he said at face
value
trisha cannot say anything she wants
about either of you because trisha has
spent
years of her life with the vlog squad
and she's been talking about it for
years what is the alarming oh
you have your vaccine oh [ __ ] i have to
go
how let me check how far is it i think i
did it early
um i'm going to get my vaccine today
it's awesome thank you um
not only that but trisha was there that
night
you don't [ __ ] you [ __ ]
she was there she's in the video
she spent time so it's like your whole
argument is like oh [ __ ] anyone could
say you are you
you you pathetic is completely
scary and scary no there are scary to
you probably because you guys are
scumbags
yeah i mean that's the only thing i get
from it is okay tell me why is it so
scary let's talk about it i'm sure
phase blanks and mike have plenty to be
scared about
areas of it that are that are helpful
and and i think you know trisha would
say this and and
other people would say this where people
have continued to skate the line and not
been taken down by authorities because
of power because of their elite status
whatever and now you have these guys are
always like i'm
so proud of the movement and it's so
necessary
so you have like 20 minutes before you
have to leave okay
good you know what these guys are always
like
i'm so pro the movement
and the need for it and everything but
once it skirts a little bit too close to
me
it was a boy's club and trisha couldn't
say anything about anyone and get any of
us in trouble
faze blinks phase galaxy brain
and mike we need a good name for mike
mike [ __ ] my gym shorts
unfortunately i don't think it doesn't
really roll off the tongue
i i think it's funny slick in arabic
means like
like skink i mean nice nice slick yeah
mike magic
wake up
[Music]
it almost looks like it says jail mike
my jail if you take out the
let's keep this i have a new way to hold
people accountable but i think it is a
very very dangerous game that we're
playing here with cancel culture
which also is equally as scary and [ __ ]
like you know what's
actually scary is people abusing people
and nothing happens and there's no
repercussions and
they just go on and succeed even more in
life and how about that's actually scary
oh yeah and to the victim seeing that
and also by the way guys i recommend
reading the [ __ ]
article yeah this isn't a game
first of all stupid and also
it's it's it's not just cancel culture
it's actually kind of cool to see that
people can hold other people accountable
and get something done
i got two points to make all right first
of all go ahead keemstar
well banks i know you didn't see the new
dramaalert but i'm just going to briefly
explain it how do you know that
and how do you know that because you're
because of what you just said so what
you're talking about
how phase blanks man you really
are a stooge misogynistic mic
i don't know if that i don't know if
he's a massage he certainly sounds like
it
it needs to rhyme with his name yes no
[ __ ] shorts mike [ __ ] shorts
mike shit's short i i just [ __ ] my gym
shorts
come on zach we can't do that i like
love said mike [ __ ]
shorts i'm kind of liking that mike
well maybe you did i don't know maybe
you do love me i saw it okay
so 2017 elisha daniel starts coming out
with
claims that dom from the vlog squad
was touchy feely with his friends right
and then more
i'd have to listen but shout out to
keemstar for actually being uh
for actually not being so the worst
very important stuff at that point in
the show is that
was he talking [ __ ] about me where in
the very beginning he can't resist
oh right oh we don't want to go down
that because that was right we left
around the same time i was ready to
offer
uh olive ranch to keemstar
they're liars they're full of [ __ ]
keemstar would you like to be friends
with me
very hypocritical
i can't imagine him wanting to be
friends with such a hypocrite
so let's see we've got that [ __ ] those
guys
especially faze blanks i feel like mike
was just going along with it because
he's like i'm an idiot i'm a [ __ ]
as trisha says he's a picnic man he
totally is a pikmi boy
it's like he just plays along just be
like me me i agree i agree i want to be
i want to be in with you guys i don't
want to be your friend mike is
definitely a pick me
face blank gym shorts
yes sex thank you
let's see oh here's another my
okay i know
i don't know why but faze banks uh
twitter profile
what with the money no just the the hit
is like tagline or whatever it just
always makes me laugh there's just
something so
stupid about it
just a random kid who was born to be a
loser
but [ __ ] around on the internet and
made a life for himself
you want to break that down
i don't know it's just i can't explain
it it's just every time i've
i've seen it he's been brought up on the
show and i pull it up it just
it makes me cringe so hard phase blinks
ladies and gentlemen
i think but nothing happens what's that
three stages i
i i try to think but nothing happens
that's fine
but nothing happens i try to think but
nothing happens
oh there's more guys there's so much
good stuff today i'm
running out of time i didn't know that
was we were gonna have this conversation
about blanks
but jesus yeah
that got me they had this fight
okay so mike uh mike
mike [ __ ] pants [ __ ] the pants
magi-lick right yeah also got also
gotten to beef with logan paul for being
a total [ __ ] douchebag
and again now i feel like i feel like
i'm team logan paul i'd be coming
i've i've gained respect for logan paul
only
i mean he dedicated like an hour and a
half now an [ __ ] he was like
two weeks ago yeah because of the coven
stuff like he's a coven dinner
and he called you the scum of the
internet and then like triggered a
[ __ ] movie
i'm very pretty
also he said he wished that you were the
one that was getting uh
oh his wish came through oh there you go
yeah no maybe i would love it maybe it's
him careful what you wish for
let me tell you about banana let me tell
you about
bananas oh no i'm a strawberry
so wait let me make sure i'm clicking
this right so they had this debate
earn a dress doing whippets
do you guys remember he's blowing up a
balloon
harry styles wore a dress and a vote
cover and
like who cares right it's like it's like
it's bro it's 20 21 like fine who gives
a [ __ ]
it was cool yeah i think it's cool too
i'd [ __ ] him
and and so anyway they have this whole
debate
just in all the wrong places no but look
okay so
to me i see this and i'm like what
[ __ ] g
like he don't he don't give a [ __ ] right
right wait is that really what you think
or is that what you're saying but like i
swear to god i swear
he's wearing a dress like your immediate
thought is wow this guy's a real
gangster yeah
yep because i'm all about challenging
social norms
i swear i swear i'm old school man i
like the way it is
like challenging covet status
masks cultural norm
maybe i have super power filming corpses
challenge the norm okay sorry over that
but yeah
yeah i agree with him on that i totally
agree with you freaking blueberry
what is the way it is the way it's been
why because the way it's been has not
been great
well i just mean just because like all
like 10 minutes and all are great
especially for men and just you know but
if you think about it
listen if we switch the roles i feel
like the access for us to pee would be a
lot easier on a dress
that i mean it's a good point listen and
that's why he might have been doing it
listen
i watched a whole thing from uh uh uh uh
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna forget his name now
the hbo
uh pull it up bill mulligan is an entire
uh like ten minute dialogue
he says well there's a point where they
start arguing and he's like
i know i'm just i'm switching gears a
little bit but i can't tell you to hold
on you tell me
okay well anyway this was a while ago
and now
mike during that recent uh shooting the
blanks podcast
starts talking [ __ ] on logan paul
who's harry styles with the dress with
the dressing i provided a different
viewpoint because i'm going to be honest
with you
there are a lot of times where logan is
can be a dick rider on [ __ ] and i was
providing a [ __ ]
on on stuff like that like if lo i'm
gonna be honest if logan sees an
opportunity with a celebrity of that
stature of harry styles
he's gonna say something on the podcast
to squeeze it into the red
like he didn't come off that show and i
would say this directly
he was here straight up i would tell him
he didn't come off this that show like
wow we did a great job pushing for the
the wearers of
male wearing of dresses like he did that
because he knew it was going to get
clipped
it was going to give him you know a hand
up in obviously once again this is just
this weird game that everyone's playing
all right that's that's everything is a
game
by the way to go on someone else's
podcast and [ __ ] on your call
like i feel like that i agree with logan
why do you need to get so up in arms
about a dude wearing a dress
so then logan that's
this is a lot of drama anyway logan put
our response he's like [ __ ] mike
you want to read that
i mean mike would be nothing without
logan why is he
like [ __ ] such a shitty golden egg
it's not even
it's so honest it's that he's basically
calling his friend disingenuous liar
he said here logan went in he said i'm
gonna find your ass in a [ __ ] force
and film you next [ __ ]
he said this upsets me and i wish i
hadn't seen it
mike will change his character based on
who he's with a pick me man like i said
who he's with and what room he's in
everyone in the house knows this and
it's been an issue in the past
especially when we go out these guys
still live together
i think so man zach you're millionaires
like
you're going to have 11 with your
buddies you're going to have less
housemates than logan paul
it's an issue in the house everyone
knows this and it's been going on
especially when we uh
go can you ask elizabeth to prepare a
coffee for me to go
okay thank you
very urgent well i'm gonna have to leave
like right afterwards
i try my hardest to help him shed that
very
ugly part of his personality ooh
oh he said i've caught mike in lies
before and i try my hardest
to help him shed that very ugly part of
his personality but evidently there's
been no progress
he'll make things up to further his
agenda everything he said
here is not true george can attest if i
was even more fired up before especially
after the podcast
when they couldn't see him who cares
they're all douches
definitely i shouldn't move on mike's
yeah and
it doesn't matter because what he's
saying could easily be interpreted as
like that's just your feeling
doesn't i mean talk about
they just criticized us for playing
games with people's
lives it's like you just sound bitter
phase blanks made it sound like we have
a whole fbi
operation with the command center all
looking over
every david vlog ever made trying to
crack like crunch the algorithm on which
one would
create a yeah it's like bro
i will say that i have gained points for
logan
and keemstar today wild on a scale
of zero on a scale of minus 100 to zero
they're both at minus 99.
not bad i guess i have to wrap it up
even though i have a bunch of really
great [ __ ] so
it's [ __ ] outrageous yeah but the
cinnamon toast shrimp gate
you know they the vaccines are becoming
really available so i recommend everyone
to start checking
what websites and see if you can get one
we're in a um
we're in a uh what do you call it
essential field now because we're in
production video production and
but it's becoming like really well
there's like five million vaccines in
one day in america
wow that's a lot of it 19.
so they said sign up so i just put my
name on the list and they called me
so hopefully i'm not late because i want
that shot do you know which one i'm
getting
i do not i kind of want pfizer for no
particular reason
you don't want that good good that jay
and jay it's not that one shot
i want it done that good good that top
shelf i'll tell you what i like not that
i want no it's the one that's two shots
so it's either pfizer or madonna
i like jay and jay because it's one shot
but i only get one shot i like that you
get your
shots did you get your johnson johnson
girl
the the johnson junction one's weird
because it's only one
shot i got it you know i have to get
back
in your vaccine i know that like in the
banks
no one buys
or something is it johnson johnson or
johnson and janssen because i
i don't know if it's the same company
because i swear i've seen it spelled
differently no i'm not [ __ ] kidding
i saw someone spell it differently
okay hold on johnson
playing that today um
i mean if there's any other parents in
the chat let me know if you guys agree
but i've always heard like why are you
like from
johnson johnson no no no that's [ __ ]
oh they're called she okay baby hold on
before you guys [ __ ] make fun of me
it's called the jansen pharmaceutical
company
uh it's called jansen
pharmaceuticals okay
the company that makes it so it was
it's made by janssen pharmaceutical
companies
wait so it's not just johnson johnson
i don't know but i know it's made by
jansen can you turn off the [ __ ]
hotel
i see it's a so jansen pharmaceuticals
is owned by john johnson okay
okay okay they got it wow he is such an
idiot
that's that i got i got nothing you said
i got faith
you said johnson and jansen that's not a
thing
but i can see why because here you
confuse it yes it says it says
johnson's yeah
covet no that i i would actually take
the jansens for sure
one shot it's a what's interesting about
the jansen it's a little less
effective but it's very effective
at preventing severe covet illness you
know what i'm saying
so it's like so okay
the johnson johnson one is made by this
jansen pharmaceuticals right i see
jansen pharmaceuticals is a
belgian company so it's based in europe
oh the
pfizer one came from germany did the
modern
one come from a european country too one
of them we made this whole big stink
about this giant
push to get the vaccines here in america
and we're like so proud of ourselves
it's
like we didn't even well we i think
except except is the modern one american
because i know the pfizer one is
is a german researcher besides advisor
the
america fund gave a shitload of money to
fund it so all the time they put up
money yeah
tons of money got it the the operation
the moms in the chat agree with me but
uh about what moderna is based in yeah i
don't know what is that but johnson and
johnson
um it's like no one buys a baby product
they really
lost all the reputation why because they
put like a little lead there was an
apple sauce what's the big deal there's
like baby powder that was
oh it was the baby powder controversy
yeah
or talk about it or something well but
that being said
i it's not that i don't recommend
getting that vaccine i would
what times my my what time's my
point um you gotta leave it out i
literally have to leave yeah
let's wrap it up and it's not a
drive-through that's annoying you have
to get out of my car
oh complaining oh no okay i'm gonna go
did you do you have yours
did you get your shots i'm about to be
able to say yes
yes thanks for watching guys i got it
i got it i got it oh i can say that i
got it
i got it i got it
guys i love you guys i
love the foot soldiers such a fun time
i love being out here with you guys to
everyone saying you like stay
um i appreciate the compliment but
there's no way i would ever have the
confidence to do that do what they want
me to stay without you
oh i have to go so do you guys wrap up
no i mean i can wrap it up thank you
guys
you can't do anything you guys mean
lately has just been overwhelming and so
positive and so beautiful and lovely
please don't put me on a pedestal i
can't deal with that i'm not a saint or
interesting or like i'm not the arbiter
i'll take funny but just i don't like
the whole pedestal like arbiter of truth
like the whole batman
spider-man whatever don't do that to me
that being said
i'm i'm gonna go get my shot
and i'll see you guys at the usual time
next week love you bye
all right all right bye-bye
that's a wrap ethan actually wrapped up
the show for once yeah right
he didn't just walk away and gave a
whole
little button on the whole thing all
right well i'm starting the music well
thank you everyone
um bye bye we love you we love you we
love each and every one of you
right and you are very special
what you gonna do with the event
gaps with all the guests you'll see the
best podcasts in the world take it from
me jc
over cherry xp baby we podcast
now you're watching h to the three
three three
[Music]
honestly shredder will start rapping